what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we have I am Groot John how are you I
am Groot well before you skip ahead to the
reaction uh just gonna give you guys a heads
up since there are five short films and they're
remarkably short films uh it's super short we
are just gonna do two videos out of this so we're
gonna watch episodes one through three and that's
gonna be in this video and then the second video
is going to be episodes four and five that's how
the upload is gonna go on this but guys thank you
so much for being here with that in mind subscribe
and click that notification Bell to become a
citizen of the reject Nation but mainly to get
notified what the reaction for four and five
are up here on the channel leave a like that
helps us out plenty doesn't take too much on your
end to ask for also full-length Reaction watch
along three sync up with the time code or your
own copy or over at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects become a super sexy reject today
all right well let's get to it but before that
the team had proper thank you for helping us set
up these down all right now let's really get to it
what huh
VHS was in the 80s
wow that is beautiful I saw the
ship in the background there foreign
spa day
and then baby Groot invented bath bombs
wow this one like Avatar stuff beautiful
wow Chia Pet
s
okay I am tree I am shrub I am Groot
oh he likes it
it's kind of creepy
huh I swear
cool yeah it takes some of his mud with you
I'm trying to sleep hmm
quiet squirrel bird did you oh my oh my
God dark sensibilities you got great yeah
after all that he just stole it that's
hilarious that was that was very very
charming and a little twisted yeah I like it
the animation too is beautiful indeed one indeed
yeah I gotta get a good misting in
Peter puffs
it needs to repot him in a bigger pot
wow guys
possible
yeah he's a guy creepy
help oh
no
wow
this is like my left foot with my left Groot
Daniel Day-Lewis did the voices episode
what kind of wood's gonna pop out
it's wood you know what a joke that was me
uh uh well you know say if you got big feet
blank a minute of planks
every morning downward dog
foreign
these are surprisingly super enjoyable
I know well I don't know why I'm so
surprised by how enjoyable these are well
because they're like classic in a way like
because you can't really speak they go
back to that just visual storytelling
you know animated personality and you also
don't get those Pixar short films anymore
you kind of get that Vibe down oh yeah
it feels like they put their resources
we've got group bathing the Rebirth of this group
traumatized Groot dark episode yeah
the sci-fi horror ones yeah
this is the Dead Space episode
dropping a log
IC
foreign
dancing with the bark
try again oh wow
that I could really improve your dancing
guy's gonna freeze to death in the vacuum of
space I love the unexpected dark humor man yes
brood is a prideful cast
oh God that was fun
okay let's watch next series I'm sad we're already
more than halfway with birthdays I hope they do
more I hope every year they do a few uh we'll talk
a little bit we're going to the next two right now
um yeah that was um that was super fun that what
I'm really enjoying about it right now is getting
like I don't know how necessary these chapters are
in groot's life but they're very enjoyable and it
really did dot on me like how what the direction
of The Voice work must be like for Vin Diesel to
be voicing group because you really do get you
know what he's saying yeah a lot of the time and
even though he just has says I am Groot but the
the wide varieties of the like certain lines like
got you you know you know yeah yeah yeah right
there yeah you know what he's saying even though
all he has says I am Groot but but it's because
of that variety of different delivery and that
also presents uh like it's like the same three
words yet it could be really funny a variety of
ways and I do like I said I am liking the darker
sensibilities to just kind of come unexpectedly
and yeah and and the different tones that you're
getting it's it's it is really enjoyable and I
like picking up on on things without it relying on
dialogue forwards this is like short and sweet and
cute as they are there's so that is very like
beautiful and Escapist about it yeah like they
kind of have the best of of what I associate with
like classic animated shorts which is yeah they're
like very fun and quirky and they're very visually
driven and they're very imaginative and you know
beautiful obviously but there is that sense of
sort of rhiness and and like you said dark humor
that I think is really well pitched here because
it's like kids will absolutely enjoy these and
have fun with these and will probably not really
register some of those darker tones but the darker
tones that are there feel appropriate to the
character but also definitely like something
more to aimed towards us yeah it's like it's
like my cob humor yeah yeah exactly and it's
in character and it's within the universe but
it strikes this really nice balance where like
the Whimsy and the lightness and the cuteness
makes total sense and doesn't feel out of place
whatsoever and yet it still doesn't feel that far
removed from the rest of the MCU yeah yeah so like
yeah even though these aren't like setting up
major you know Easter egg threads or whatever
they're gonna become hugely important that we
know of I mean you got the rebirth journey and
then you got I guess when he learned to dance
yeah yeah what do you got his legs back you
got a little pot he learned how to dance yeah
yeah um found a fashion style too anyway yeah
yeah exactly we're gonna watch the next two
but before we head out let's do a patreon
Chase Gardner guess what buddy today it's your
shout out because we're in the world of a little
tree man he's got a little Bonsai friend you're
the perfect person to come help out Bonsai you
are the Mr Miyagi racism I don't know what your
ethnic background is I don't know the more people
in this world than Mr Miyagi work with bonsai
trees but you know you would be the perfect
person if Groot had to have anybody other than
the Guardians of the Galaxy to look after him to
be His companion it would be you chase Gardner
because you are a friendly caring good-hearted
person but you know you take care of business
when you need to because that's what gardening's
about pulling the weeds but nurturing the
foliage you know how did I miss there's a
gardener or the Galaxy joke right there so I
hope you're doing well I hope you're nurturing
your own life and we love you and we'll catch you
soon catch you soon Chase thanks for being here